en este vídeo vamos a platicar acerca de
voltaje así que creo que es muy
importante hacer una distinción entre
dos conceptos que se parecen mucho pero
son distintos el primero es energía
potencial eléctrica lo voy a poner aquí
energía potencial eléctrica esto es de
lo que ya estuvimos platicando en los
vídeos pasados potencial eléctrica
y el otro es potencial eléctrico
potencial
y eléctrico
entonces los nombres se parecen mucho
pero hay que tener cuidado con no
confundirlos hasta ahorita solo hemos
platicado de la energía potencial
eléctrica y la principal diferencia
entre dos entre estos dos conceptos es
que la energía potencial eléctrica tiene
que ver con una partícula puesta en una
cierta posición y con una carga con una
carga que ya tenía asociada como lo
vimos en vídeos pasados por otro lado el
potencial eléctrico solo tiene que ver
con la posición y no se preocupa con que
carga tenemos en ese punto vale después
si colocamos una carga en ese punto
ahora sí conociendo su potencial
eléctrico y la carga que estamos
poniendo podemos determinar su energía
potencial eléctrica pero vamos a hacer
vamos a hacer ejemplos para dejar esto
bien claro y para esto déjame pintar a
nuestra placa favorita que es la placa
la placa infinita uniformemente cargada
sólo que ahora la voy a poner así
verticalmente para para variar le un
poco va entonces ahí está una placa
placa infinita uniformemente cargada
vamos a pensar que tiene carga positiva
positiva y como hemos platicado en
vídeos pasados el campo eléctrico de
esta placa es constante aquí iría hacia
la derecha porque si ponemos una
partícula cargada positivamente por aquí
entonces se iría hacia la derecha y
entonces el campo eléctrico se vería más
o menos hacia flechitas hacia la derecha
todas de la misma magnitud va todas de
la misma magnitud
muy bien ahora vamos a poner por aquí
una carga vamos a poner una carga de 2
colones déjame ponerla por acá de dos
culos y vamos a pensar que que también
es positiva va que también es positiva
vamos a pensar que está a tres metros de
nuestra placa le voy a poner aquí tres
metros y que queremos moverla hasta que
quede a un metro hasta que quede a un
metro de distancia sale o sea queremos
moverla dos metros
esto de aquí es dos metros entonces
bueno vamos a hacer primero la
diferencia de energía potencial
eléctrica que es lo que ya hicimos en
vídeos pasados y la vamos a encontrar
con respecto con respecto a este punto
de acá vale vamos a encontrar el
potencial eléctrico aquí con respecto a
este punto de acá entonces cuál era la
idea la idea es que tenemos que
determinar el trabajo necesario para
llevar la partícula cargada de aquí acá
para esto tenemos que ejercer una cierta
fuerza por esta distancia que es de dos
metros eso nos va a dar el trabajo y por
lo tanto la la energía potencial
eléctrica
la fuerza que tenemos que aplicar justo
tiene que ser la fuerza que contrarresta
la fuerza eléctrica que genera el campo
eléctrico vale que genera la placa
infinita bueno entonces pues vamos a
poner todo esto para para resolverlo
pero sabes que necesito también decir
está igual cuál es el campo eléctrico de
la placa entonces vamos a ponerle que es
d
qué es campo eléctrico es de digamos 3
newtons por culo ok entonces otra vez la
idea es contrarrestar la fuerza
eléctrica causada por este campo
entonces primero tenemos que determinar
la fuerza vamos a hacer eso entonces
vamos a determinar la fuerza eléctrica
causada por el campo y esta estaba dada
multiplicando el campo y campo por la
carga que queremos mover entonces sería
igual a 3 newton coloms por 2 colom se
los colomos que es igual a 6 newtons y
ya conociendo la fuerza ahora sabemos
que tenemos que ejercer esa fuerza por 2
metros tenemos que ejercer una fuerza de
esta magnitud hacia la izquierda por 2
metros entonces el trabajo
el trabajo que tenemos que realizar es
fuerza por distancia que es igual a 6
newtons por estos 2 metros de acá 2
metros esto es igual a 12 newtons metros
o bien 12 jules muy bien entonces este
es el trabajo necesario para mover esta
carga de aquí a este punto de acá a este
punto de acá y por lo tanto es justo
esto es la diferencia de energía
potencial eléctrica entre estos dos
puntos de acá otra forma de pensarlo es
que este punto tiene una mayor energía
potencial eléctrica que éste y que esta
energía esta energía potencial eléctrica
es 12 jules mayor a la del punto de acá
vale entonces lo podemos pensar justo
como una diferencia de energía potencial
eléctrica entonces eso es energía
potencial eléctrica lo que ya hemos
hecho ahora para el potencial eléctrico
lo que tenemos que hacer es esto de aquí
arriba este trabajo que estamos haciendo
pero por unidad de carga o sea por cada
unidad de carga que estamos
poniendo vale entonces como nos quedaría
si estoy aquí es el trabajo entonces el
trabajo por unidad de carga tendría que
o sea tenemos que dividir wv en 13 que
es la carga tendríamos que dividir estos
dos ejes estos 12 jules entre la carga
que es de 2 kilos 2 kilos
entonces nos quedaría 6 jules oms
jules entre colom se sale entonces estoy
aquí es la diferencia de potencial
eléctrico de potencial eléctrico lo que
es diferente con lo que hicimos arriba
es que arriba ya pusimos una carga y la
carga si nos importa pero aquí abajo
como ya estamos dividiendo entre la
carga ya no nos importa pues de cuando
fue la carga sólo como que esto nos está
dando cuál es el trabajo por carga vale
ok entonces esto de aquí es el potencial
eléctrico es como la energía potencial
pero por carga bueno a la diferencia de
potencial eléctrico o sea la diferencia
de energía potencial eléctrica por carga
también se le conoce como voltaje no voy
a poner por aquí
un voltaje
vuelta de voltaje entonces esto de aquí
es la diferencia de potencial eléctrico
y la unidad de voltaje son los músculos
pero esos tienen un nombre que es volts
entonces esto de aquí es igual a 6 volts
vale 6 volts ahora si quieres hacer la
analogía con la gravedad como lo
hacíamos en los primeros videos en los
cuales platicamos de energía potencial
eléctrica pues la analogía sería la
siguiente la energía potencial
gravitacional está dada multiplicando la
masa por g por h sale entonces la
analogía sería no fijarse en la energía
potencial gravitacional sino en la
energía potencial gravitacional pero por
unidad de masa entonces como que en este
caso en el caso de la gravedad nos
fijaríamos en g por h y entonces ahí
tendríamos no sé como un potencial
gravitacional por así decirlo pero bueno
no quiero confundirte cita confundió un
poco esto no me hagas caso regresemos
acá la utilidad de tener el voltaje es
que pues ya nos habla de la diferencia
de potencial sin importar la carga
únicamente le importa la posición
está digamos está con respecto a esta o
está con respecto a esta pero sin
importar qué carga pongamos ahí después
si nos importa la carga pues ya nada más
tenemos que multiplicar por la carga y
con eso podríamos encontrar la
diferencia de energía potencial
eléctrica bueno en el siguiente vídeo
vamos a ver un poco más de ejemplos para
agarrarle más la onda a esto de
diferencia de potencial eléctrico o bien
voltaje hasta la próxima